Right now, they are trying to ban us
from telling the truth about sugar. What
if just saying sugar is harmful could
actually get you sued? It's not because
it's not true. It's because a powerful
industry does not like criticism. What
I'm going to talk about might sound
completely unbelievable, but there is a
bill right now that they're trying to
pass that if it goes through is going to
be disastrous. Okay? not just about
trigger, about a lot of other things
that are harmful to us. This is not
about a food safety law. This is about a
speech law. It controls who is allowed
to criticize agriculture and who isn't.
And it uses something called defamation
as a weapon. Florida already has a law
that allows farmers to sue someone who
spreads false information about food.
This is sometimes called food liel or
food disparagement. The original idea
was simple. Don't lie about fresh
produce and destroy the farmer's
livelihood. At least that's how it was
sold to the public. But that's not how
it's being used. Certain investigative
journalists uncovered internal documents
from large agriculture and chemical
companies. And in those documents showed
the real goal, which had nothing to do
with protecting farmers, and instead it
had everything to do with what to do
with critics, environmental groups,
journalists, activists, scientists. The
strategy was to make lawsuits so
expensive, so unpredictable that people
would stop talking about it, even if
they were right. The term for this is
called chilling free speech. Here is
where the current bill becomes very
dangerous. The old law only applied to
perishable foods because it limited the
law to things like fruits and vegetables
that spoil quickly. So, it kept it very
narrow. The new bill removes the word
perishable. That one little tiny change
quietly expands the law to all
agricultural products, including sugar.
But it goes further. The bill also adds
a new phrase, any agricultural practice
used in production. That means criticism
of pesticides, insecticides, fungicides,
fertilizer, chemical runoff, water
contamination, all now can be treated as
disparagement. I mean, everyone knows
that excessive sugar is bad for the
body, right? Insulin resistance, fatty
liver, chronic inflammation, type 2
diabetes. This is not just opinion. This
is an established fact. But if this bill
goes through and someone speaks out
about sugar or pesticides or whatever on
how it can affect your health or how
it's even produced, even if it's
truthful, a powerful company could sue
you. And so now that puts an activist or
an influencer who's talking about sugar
in a situation where now they have to
pay for legal costs. But not only that,
if they lose the case, now that
individual has to then pay the other
attorney's fees. Now, this bill is
coming out of Florida, okay? But even if
you don't live in Florida, this matters
because Florida crops are sold
nationwide. Legal experts warn that this
could open the door to lawsuits that go
way beyond the state. And this sets a
very dangerous precedent. Florida
already has defamation laws and we
absolutely do not need more special
legal protection for powerful industries
like the sugar industry, like the
pesticide industry. And then what
happens is you can't debate these things
because the threat of a lawsuit or a
threat of some type of punishment. So
when I first saw this bill, I was like,
what the heck are they doing now? If you
live in Florida, or even if you don't
live in Florida, you have to help fight
this because if this bill goes through,
think about what the ultrarocessed food
companies can get away with. The
chemical companies are going to be able
to get away with. They're protected
against anyone criticizing them. Now,
this bill on the outside has the
appearance that it's just there to help
support the farmers, but if you read
between the lines, the law is designed
to silence the critics. And once free
speech is silence, public health is
next. I mean, this is a pretty smart
thing that these big companies are
doing. If they can get this passed, they
get so much protection against
criticism. So, when I was looking at
this, I'm like, what is this playbook
called? Well, it's actually called
weaponized defamation law, or another
name for it is using lawsuits to silence
criticism. So I think a lot of
influencers,
activists,
scientists would literally be very quiet
because the amount of money that you
would be sued for would literally drain
your resources. So if you have the same
viewpoint I have, ultrarocessed food is
responsible for 80% of chronic disease.
I highly recommend you click the link
down below where you can actually sign
up on a petition. If you live in
Florida, you can call your local
representative and complain. But we need
to make a lot of noise right now because
if this bill goes through, it's going to
be devastating for our children, for
their grandkids, and for us as well. So,
please click the link down below and
let's all work together to defeat this